do you have sleepiness after you eat let's
talk about why that is and what to do about it
now they call that a food coma or postprandial somnolence or maybe even a siesta but what you have
to realize it's not normal for you to be tired
after you eat because you're getting fuel right
you're supposed to have more energy but why do
people get tired well mainly because they're doing
high carb in fact i used to use carbs to help my
sleeping because i had such a sleeping problem
i used to consume a pint of ben and jerry's ice
cream right before bed for a very long time and
it would just put me right out i would go right
to sleep of course i'd wake up all puffy and
feeling funky and irritable and then i would
keep the cycle going over and over and over
because every time i did it it affected my blood
sugars then late at night i would crave carbs
okay now i've done all the videos on this but i
wanted to do this one specifically talking about
keto you started keto you're doing intermittent
fasting and you're still tired what's going on
it could be that you don't have enough
hydrochloric acid in your stomach
so you could just take some apple cider vinegar or
obtain hydrochloride as a supplement when you eat
that might help but it's usually not the big
problem now it also could be that your your
cells because you have insulin resistance are just
not able to pull in the nutrients and the fuel
but it's probably true but it's not
actually the thing that's making you tired
if you're not getting nutrients and you're
not getting fuel you're going to feel
like you're not satisfied like you need to
eat something else but you usually are not
going to be tired the real reason why you're tired
involves insulin resistance but it has to do with
high insulin because when the insulin is high it
blocks certain brain chemicals that are supposed
to keep you awake so it's really the high insulin
that's causing this problem but wait a second i
thought lowering your carbs is going to lower
insulin and i just started keto that's true but
there's two things that increase your insulin
number one it's the carb number two it's eating
you just ate and eating triggers insulin and the
problem is you've had insulin resistance for so
long that it's going to take some time to correct
the high levels of insulin that's occurring
because you still have insulin resistance so even
if you don't eat carbs eating triggers insulin
okay so what can we do well number one you need to
start doing intermittent fasting right why because
eating less is going to make you more awake
and eating makes you hungry which then triggers
fatigue so if we skip the breakfast that would be
a very smart thing to do okay just do two meals
and start to squish them together slowly so you
can fast longer because you're going to find out
you have more energy when you're fasting you're
going to have more energy when you're not eating
because you're not triggering this mechanism
so intimate fasting is vitally important
a lot of people that just started keto they're not
including intermittent fasting enough and so this
is why they still are tired also make sure that
you keep your carbs low okay so just be aware of
that and look at your carbs and make sure they're
within the range that you need to do number three
moderate protein you're going to find out the
more protein you do the more tired you're going
to be because a high protein meal will make you
tired now if you combine the high protein with a
high carb you're really going to get tired as in
thanksgiving which is the starch and the protein
together just will put you out it's not the
tryptophan it's the combination of a starch with
protein but a large amount of protein can make
you tired so just do a moderate amount number four
give it time it takes between one to three
months to be keto adapted okay that means
you're really getting insulin resistance under
control and you're able to uh go from one meal
to the next without being hungry and that's a big
indication that it's working now in the meantime
you can do things to speed up your insulin
resistance and one thing because this involves
feeling sleepy is just to try to get a little
bit more sleep another 30 minutes will help you
a simple way to do that would be to go to bed a
little earlier take vitamin b1 i usually get my b1
through nutritional yeast take that right before
bed and vitamin d3 especially during the winter
so vitamin d3 right before bed will help you
sleep you should give it a try and see for
yourself all right thanks for watching and i
will see you in the next video so if you're
enjoying my content which i hope you are and
you're applying this knowledge to your health
and you have a success i'd really appreciate you
sharing your success story so click the link down
below to my website where you can upload your
success story so you can help inspire others